a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free State the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed unless like
guns get way more advanced than today
because this thing is totally about
hunting you guys I'm super serious
like if the gun can fire more than one
round in a minute or if it can hold like
a crap ton of bullets I don't know 10 or
se5 I don't know you can just change
this thing whenever when there's guns
that can have too many bullets in them
you'll totally know also if the guns are
a super scary color or if the rifle can
have that like you know one of those
more vertical grips instead of the
horizontal thing then the whole thing is
off we can't have people protecting the
security of a free state by hunting with
scary black guns that can hold a few
extra bullets and have that vertical
grip that would just be crazy insanity
because again this thing is like totally
for hunting I'm as serious as scurvy
people I'm leaving this whole
Constitution thing really open to
interpretation so that the right people
can maybe come along and capture what
I'm truly trying to say here hopefully
some reasonable people who've never
actually fired weapons before I think
could offer like a super fresh
perspective maybe like some women yeah
that'd be perfect I'm picturing like
some stay-at-home moms who are really
looking for a cause something to sink
their teeth into maybe they can take the
Second Amendment deal and really take it
under their wing you know start a
support group the point I'm trying to
make here is that the whole part about
the well-regulated militia and the right
to bear arms that's really just a
footnote the real takeaway here is that
people should only be allowed to have
certain guns because this thing is like
totally for hunting
regardless of his servitude Jesus never
demanded anything in return from these
women all right no I got it go into no
more
whereas Mohammed had quite a few slaves
and concubines please not Mohammed tell
me how I can please you you can make me
a sandwich